[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  so  we now have first person intel from  inside the west view anomaly  what are we looking at here is it an  alternate reality  time travel it's a sitcom  starring two avengers that's a working  theory  well i know the apron is a bit much dear  but i am doing my best to blend in  hello dear kid hi kiddo life moves  pretty fast out in the suburbs  i think something's wrong here should we  just take it from the top  i don't know how any of this started  what is outside of westfield  yeah i'm not sure what that's about it's  probably just a case of the mondays  am i right  is this really happening yes my love  are you crying but i'm invested  [Music]  you